listen I'm trying to question about the
movies but I like throwing a curveball
at the beginning if someone is actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why
wow that's a great question
wait what was the question if if you if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before what is the uh why that's a
tough one so let's let's break it down
to specificities are you talking are you
talking about the film performances or
just everything I mean because I can I
can say they probably get to know me
pretty well if they watched you know the
video of my group kindergarten
graduation uh
there was there was something going on
in this this young kid that was yearning
to explode out of me so they probably
get a good sense of what my future was
to become just wow
that's Fast Master guys in that video if
it's film wise I'd say you know I was
very proud of achieving and and being
able to do this wonderful Journey that
was on the road with Walter Sellers and
wonderful casts and the whole B
generation Kerouac Adventure yeah
or Empower uh impactful for me in my
life probably I wouldn't suggest that
they watch uh my Ovaltine commercial or
what I've got
everything ready to just get a sense of
who I am as an artist
I'm gonna do that back to back with with
a Christmas story and just have the
greatest day yeah
yeah I would say for me my my
performance in Aladdin when I was nine
years old
um yeah I think
singing a whole new world really shown
it helped me shine I appreciate you
indulging me
um jumping into why I get to talk to you
one of the things I enjoy about movies
is when I'm not sure ultimately who the
antagonist and the protagonist is in a
story so I'm curious when you guys were
reading this script how much did like
your agent or manager or Jordan tell you
and how much were they sort of saying
read the script and let's see what you
think well I I went into it I didn't
know anything about this film my agents
just sent it to me they're like check it
out we'll cast we'll director letter
grade right the Thriller I love that
genre so I didn't really know much else
about it and I was immediately hooked in
when I started reading it it was a page
trailer for me and I didn't know what
was going to happen next I was intrigued
I was like how's this going to end
um and I thought it was really exciting
it kept me on the edge of my seat and so
that was really what was exciting for me
and then obviously you know having the
opportunity to get to work with these
two amazing actors this was very cool
and Jordan meeting with Jordan and he's
such um just such a cool guy like
someone you want to be friends with and
had such a vision for this and is kind
and collaborative and easy to work with
and so
those were all the things that were
exciting and yeah didn't know much about
it I was given this career
um
four months or so before we shot it by
the producer Rob Barnum
um he was really excited about it I read
it I you know
I hadn't been tossed a lot of
psychological thrillers before I was
hanging on the sort of every scene it
kept me on the edge of my seed and then
I kind of got to the third act and I was
like no no I don't know
and I read it again got to the third
acts and said I don't know and then it
was the third time reading I said I
think I can do something with this here
it really reminded me of
you know films like the primal fear that
that I absolutely loved and then latter
years of high school and and same thing
I was I was blown away by the ending
never could have imagined it
was one that as a viewer as an audience
as a lover of film and Cinema just was
like that it man that
uh did the job it really got me and and
I hoped that this would do the same
thing so couldn't wait to try I mean
yeah they I Echo everything they both
said I mean just reading the script
seeing seeing the the opportunities I
had to play this character
um the cast and then Victoria came on
and it was even more exciting and and
everything just came together and I I
was so excited to be a part of it you
guys obviously didn't make this with the
Marvel money and I'm just curious what
was it like when you have when you know
you really got to make it on a take or
two you know like you really gotta hit
your your schedule yeah we shopped uh
fast I think it was uh a four-week shoot
that's
you know 20 days
um we shot in Alabama uh Premiere
outside and in Birmingham
um
board New York essentially love it or
can translate it essentially any Town
anywhere
um it was left kind of pseudo open but
um it was it was it was quite a small
budget the the only and then when you
watch it and it seems like the budget
was much higher all goes to Jordan Ross
he went around and and met so many
locals from from Birmingham
and explain where we're shooting this
film explain what the film was about
this and that and so many generous
wonderful families invited us to to come
shoot in their beautiful homes and all
of a sudden we were you know shooting in
mansion after mansion after mansion on
all the way from Birmingham to Lake
Alexandria to
what have you and and
that was that was wonderful benefits so
thank you to all the wonderful families
but
um you know everybody kind of came on
the the characters were so wonderful
um and we knew that if done right it
would be something that audiences had
kind of waited for something kind of
unpredictable to to fall into their lap
and and so for us to do something that
can surprise and
and terrorize in such a way
um well jumped on kind of eager to do
our parts yeah one of the things this
movie reminds me is if someone really uh
wants to take you down and they have the
resources you're done
it wasn't really good question this is
something I said
um I actually I have an individual
question for each of you um if you don't
mind because I'm just about out of time
uh Victoria I know you recently shot I
believe California king and that has a a
cool cast if you get to talk about it
Garrett uh you're doing bass Reeves
which is another in the Taylor Sheridan
Universe what can you tease and Noah
obviously you're rapping on Stranger
Things it's gonna be your final you know
Season uh what does it mean to you to be
ending that chapter of your life
um yeah California King super excited
about that project and it's really fun I
just got to like pop in and good time my
character Lynette is kind of like this
badass she smokes and she purses a lot
and um it was it was really fun it was
like it's like an action adventure kind
of comedy and uh was able to work with
so many talented actors Jimmy Tatro
who's hysterical like improv King
incredible
um Taco Bennett Joel the kale uh it was
a really fun cast and a really fun
project and the e-line star and directed
it it says writing directorial debut and
he absolutely crushed it and I have like
this fun like dance sequence in the
movie and it's just a really just a
really fun project that like
keeps you you know keeps you going the
the entire time there's never a dull
moment so I'm really excited for people
to see that and to meet my character
Lynette yeah I'm I'm on bass Reeves
um I've been shooting it since the
beginning of
February it's it's it's fantastic what
they're achieving on this project it's
been a story that
um
many have wanted to uh to have done for
a very long time uh Davido yellow is
playing uh bass Reeves he's in a a
phenomenal actor
it's uh Taylor Sheridan once again I
love being in the the Sheridan family
we've we've tried to link up many times
before so to do Tulsa King now ambass
Reeves Paramount plus a wonderful family
Studio 101
101 Studios wonderful David Glasser and
all the guys there we got a wonderful uh
creative thing going
um
uh there's a lot of fans of the bass
Reeves story and and and I'm excited to
to be part of this one so you know
everybody can finally get what they've
been written for oh yeah and then for me
um I mean just rapping stranger things
oh so Bittersweet I mean it's it was
obviously like kind of what
made me I guess as an actor and I I it's
it's I've grown up on the show as I
first started with one day when I was 10
and now I'm like an adult
um so it's crazy but
um I mean
I'm really excited to get shooting the
the last season looks really good and
when it's over I'm I'm definitely gonna
be crying and upset but excited for what
the future holds it was definitely uh I
was gonna make a joke about Aladdin but
uh anyway I was gonna say uh thank you
all so much
um I gotta rap I'm just gonna say uh
congrats great talking with you guys and
I wish you nothing but the best thank
you